BPD patient BPD hello everybody welcome
to another episode of genius brain
I am your wonderful host georgette
Sakawa and I'm a David so and today we
have again our favorite nutrition
helping person who helps us make sure we
lose weight make sure we kick pads make
sure we break a sweat in the morning and
keep our mental sanity Nick the ear yep
hi everybody
none of that stuff is true yeah he also
wipes my butt yeah I do mostly that I
clean everyone's ass on the JK after we
should we bend over and we go I'm ready
I come in with a brown covered apron
with my black gloves and I do what I
need to do yeah he gets the Duty done
they don't even pay me I'm just happy to
be here
smell your butt can I smell your butt
please oh that's nice yeah immature Oh
didn't I phone yo so just just in case
this is [ __ ] that the topic runs away
from us again
so yo so there's a couple of topics that
people wanted to talk about that are
that's just hot [ __ ] right now
I guess it's kind of already past but
people wanted to know our opinions about
it yeah just because it has to do with
the YouTube community yes now the
interesting thing is like I sometimes
forget that youtubers are celebrities
right like yeah it's even me yeah like
it's you guys are celebrities yes sir
you guys are bigger than some like
actors and we are in the peloton PJ and
people want to want to know about our
opinions about some youtubers that [ __ ]
up a lot you know why cuz they like you
guys a lot they like you guys a lot and
they feel that they connect with you my
hope our fans like us yeah
though that's the dumbest thing I've
ever said your fans like you a lot yeah
so the first thing that people wanted to
talk for us to talk about anyways was
the whole issue with this guy named
James Charles I thought that was Brett
maroc when I first saw him they kind of
got that same Steven look yeah like my
fiancé loves Brett Monroe who does his
issue as makes me watch his videos and
I'm like who does not love that [ __ ]
hilarious flamboyant gay boy he's
growing on me
Bart said he wanted to [ __ ] him yeah
that's time that was telling geo he was
like watch out watch out geo cuz I'm a
Bart wants some of this Brett [ __ ] that
dude's got some glutes on I'd say that
he's got he's got some glutes on her for
sure thanks
he's [ __ ] weird man like he wild he's
definitely one of those like extra ass
[ __ ] gay people but he does it so
funny it makes me laugh so attitude yeah
man so stories about how people like
give him [ __ ] and then like he's in his
car like talking [ __ ] about them those
are probably my favorite ones he's gonna
flip ya cuz he's just like cuz I bet he
gets so much like [ __ ] from day to
day yeah basis where I'm like a dude
yeah there's one [ __ ] video where he
was like I think he was like trying to
pull dance or some [ __ ] and then behind
him his mom starts broomie because the
brooms are slugging cleaning via thing
in the house he's like rolling his eyes
[ __ ] get my sexy on engine yeah that
[ __ ] definitely wasn't planned he was so
irritated that should made me laugh so
hard yeah he's a [ __ ] unapologetic
that's why yeah he was telling Bart that
his dad so his dad is like super into
like WWE stuff and like so all his life
like he wanted this son that would get
into this WWE stuff but then he's all
like yeah but he got a gay boy instead
both performers dude yeah it doesn't
[ __ ] matter be like a diva like the
Divas yeah but James Charles is like
he's huge youtuber huge influencer
I think he's known for makeup first of
all right so what was the term I'm like
what is a track we make no I think he's
a makeup artist yeah but I don't I don't
know if he's transgender yeah I think
he's he's a gay dude that does makeup
really dope and he just there's like the
whole drag thing yeah see like I don't
know like what the right thing to say is
but I don't think drag is about word cuz
they have the hair Paul's drag race yeah
[ __ ] Khalif one two that [ __ ] he says
dope he would wait he went to the show
or he's in it no he he went to the show
he go he was doing a drag race yeah but
there was this whole issue with I guess
he's doing this tour thing right now
mind you I don't know what a makeup
artist does on tour cuz I think when I
when I think about tour I think about
musicians I think about life
former's but people have a huge issue
specifically his fans with how much he
was charging for his extra VIP tickets
right yeah so he had a $500 VIP and what
that would get you is like access to be
in the same room with him be able to ask
him questions and the potential to get
up on stage and he does your eyes like
my makeup okay yeah how much was that
five hundred bucks like that's fair
right
and then yeah it depends I guess like so
I want to play both sides of this
because there's there's the first
thought is this number one he's very
famous because I think his main fame bat
fanbase is really young so yeah they're
like 10 to 15 year olds yeah
500 and there was another tutor below
that which was 250 and there was another
one for like hundred and there's no one
for like 50 bucks I believe right which
is very typical of most concerts I'm not
sure about the 500 range but oh no if
you're like Lady gaga
or like I mean that's actually kind of
affordable yeah cuz I had what's it
called cuz I wanted to go to a jay-z
concert out in Oakland right but his
general admission tickets were like 200
bucks so when I saw those numbers I was
like oh it's yeah it's it's kind of that
I don't I'm not saying that I'm
comparing him to jay-z but to some of
these kids he might be jay-z right yeah
so well I mean I've got like what 17
million is at nineteen ninety nine
million subscribers that's like ten JK
news bro yeah like that's man he's
[ __ ] mad popular so a lot of these
kids were upset because they were
calling him basically a crook because he
just made these tickets so expensive and
I guess when they see that ticket price
they're saying that he's very
money-hungry and he's not really
thinking about his fans a lot so for me
like I just didn't know I guess like for
me it's more like how I see stuff like
that is a product right you don't have
to buy it yeah nobody's forcing you to
buy it and there is another option there
were options right there's still a $50
option that you can go to and when you
buy ticket still a lot of these concerts
you do have those options you had the
VIP tickets you have anything else and
so like as I mention if I wanted to go
to this jay-z concert with what Beyonce
it was 200 bucks for the general nose
police yeah and that's I guess like
that's that would be the equivalent to
what these people who are fans of James
Charles yeah views him as like I
understand the whole thing it's like yo
if you cared about your fans you would
make
cheaper and but there's still the other
side to things were it's there's a
supply and demand and there are people
who are buying on his tickets yeah I
mean you're not wrong in the business
end of things but I think when it comes
to us youtubers
we're not looked upon in the same way as
Beyonce even if like let's say PewDiePie
yeah like someone who might even be
bigger than a lot of artists just in
following and like all in presence and
whatever right but the difference is as
a youtuber we have this personal
connection accessibility factor to it
right there's this down-to-earth nough
static EEP so like the reason why you
would pay for Beyonce is because she's
out of reach so you pay that money
because there's no way in hell you're so
you're gonna ever have a chance with
that but for a youtuber you still think
like they're gonna walk around and you
can see them at the mall and in they got
they got their start so humble and they
still record in their bedroom a lot of
these big timers like they still record
on like you know it's a full-on set yeah
they have this magic of personal space
and small and everything right yeah
because like a lot of people are making
the argument like well you know your
fans are 10 years old how they gonna
afford that yeah but there's a lot of
like child famous [ __ ] like and if you
have money you can go and like like pop
stars and like boy bands and whatever
right like like if you went to a Justin
Bieber concert like and then you wanted
a [ __ ] VIP and all that stuff it's
like you're gonna be paying a lot of
money yeah yeah but I think it's the the
accessibility part where they feel like
hey man like I thought we had a personal
connection so they feel personally
slided over somebody that they actually
really don't know it's like all of a
sudden you're bougie now because I've
been following you since you were like
chill they almost feel I guess like in
that kind of sense I guess sometimes
people feel like they have a direct hand
and how awesome you are so how I was the
one that made you this way so how dare
you do this to me sometimes like it may
be to a certain extent yeah without
knowing that it's like all of a sudden
you're like this but then you know what
you're you're also talking to hot mostly
high school kids ah yeah yeah you know
yeah like I would never hear 25 year old
I'll say this yeah they do there they're
kind of stupid or they have a job cuz
they would just be like I'm gonna pay
for that [ __ ] and they move on
yeah because how I I feel like like the
market will play out itself right so if
it's something that's really
inaccessible and most people don't find
value in it they're not gonna just be
like [ __ ] this right it's kind of like
Apple products right yeah they're
grossly overpriced for it for a lot of
their stuff right you could definitely
get a PC that'll do stuff that an Apple
computer will do that would be a lot
better that's like substantially cheaper
yeah this is very well known but they
still have there's a supply and demand
for it yeah and that market will balance
itself out and people still buy it yeah
so how I view something like I said I
understand both sides but I guess like
just to play the other side it's kind of
like you guys also in that same aspect
how you have a hand in building him up
you also have that same way and turning
him down by not giving your dollars so
the best way for you to do it which
should be like oh I don't really [ __ ]
with this hey I don't want to pay for it
and once he sees like okay nobody's
paying for this then I'm obviously I
can't do a tour at this scale pay these
amount of people for this to justify the
price I think they know people are gonna
pay for it they just can't afford it so
they're bitter exactly rich kids can pay
for this cuz there are gonna be rich
parents that are like yeah I'm gonna
give my kid the [ __ ] dream you know
or like they're maybe they're not even
rich but they're the type of parents
that are like maybe they're middle-class
but they want their kids to have this
like dream that they never had you know
there's parents out there like that the
looking burn money on a plane ticket to
go to Disneyland have an all out thing
cuz they had a shitty childhood and they
don't want their kids to do that [ __ ] so
there's a lot of parents that will blow
[ __ ] money yeah so it's not the the
fact that the kids can't afford it it's
like a lot of the kids parents won't pay
for that [ __ ] yes they're pissed cuz
they're like why do you make it so
inaccessible but also like you're
talking to kids they don't [ __ ]
understand business right that's true
cuz like I see it as like well it makes
sense because I would personally charge
a lot cuz I only I want to keep it
intimate yep and then to make this worth
it like a win-win situation it's like
imagine if you only want ten people so
you could talk to every single person
and give them that respect right so how
do you balance that and it's like she
he's also giving 20 free giveaway VIP
passes to it to people in the audience
yeah so like I think general admission
was
like 10 $20 or some [ __ ] like like 50
bucks yeah okay so there's normal yes so
so that's the jobs mission right but
he's giving 20 passes for free - lucky
members in the audience that could come
to the VIP yeah and so like I think
that's pretty awesome but then like I
see it as like alright you want to spend
you want someone who's gonna spend not
because of the money aspect but then
also you wanna you want to make sure
that it's that that your meet and greets
are not 2000 people yeah you want to
make sure that you could talk to every
single person there so you could give
them that respect and care you want to
do all this [ __ ] because what people
don't understand is if you make it
accessible he's gonna be having a line
of a thousand people and then all he can
do is hi take a picture
hi take a picture yeah that's all you
can do yeah it's just it's it's kind of
weird I guess you know sometimes I feel
when when these things blow up in a lot
I think James Charles is really young
I'm not sure if he's still a teenager
but he looks super young looks really
young yeah so I'm not sure sometimes I
feel like for the the best type of PR
was [ __ ] like this happens it's just for
you to be [ __ ] honest you know don't
say stuff like listen I try I guess like
he put out this statement saying listen
I begged my team to make the make the
place it's not his fault yeah like come
on that's true like young men just as a
heads up kids are done they're not that
dumb you know what I mean yeah you you
literally beg that means like you got on
your [ __ ] like you have no control over
your own business shut up [ __ ] like
you didn't get on your knees and go yeah
you know because the venue is gonna be
like no we never had this conversation
exactly so for for you to really just
kind of face this type of backlash is
for you to try to go into their world
and explain it to them and if it doesn't
work you tried your best and at least
you were honest about it because I think
a lot of the times when people try to
like quench or just just just douse
these fires out they do it in the way
where they try to make themselves the
victim oh I'm the victim here not you
but it makes you look like [ __ ] yeah you
know because you're already trying to
make somebody who feels like a victim
that now they should pity you now it's
just like you're saying [ __ ] you to them
you know but if you said like hey yo
straight up this is what it is like this
is a very
experience and this is I believe this is
what I'm worth and if you don't want to
support I completely understand on the
next round I'm gonna learn from this and
I'm gonna try to do it again but on this
round this is what it is if you guys
want to support it thank you very much
if not imma learn from this and on the
next time I do a tour I'll make sure
that I just did for you guys yeah leave
it at that move on I mean people think
that's crazy it's like for a [ __ ]
personal boot camp with Tony Robbins
it's like $16,500 still there with a
hundred people yeah yeah so I just think
it's like ok I read into that high
school mind right cuz I was into
underground hip-hop I was like super
counterculture I was like all about
underground [ __ ] and like [ __ ]
mainstream [ __ ] like capitalism all that
stuff right and then I hated when my
artist became mainstream mm-hmm because
it was like oh you sellout do dude it's
so money hungry you have [ __ ] money
hungry like you're not a true artist man
like what's up with that but I'm not
paying my bills I don't know what it's
like to be like look I broke because of
me and I have kids to feed and I don't
know what that feels like all I think
about is oh man you're not true to your
art you're a [ __ ] fake and I bet you
they're in that same mindset they're
looking at label they're looking at
James Charles and you're like what
happened to you man greedy now is a
sellout
it's like you don't need that extra
money you're already ballin but you know
this this is this is what it is because
I feel he's gonna I'd tell everybody -
if you could cash out cash out as long
as it's not shady cash out like a
[ __ ] and pile up your money and
think about for generations how to keep
that money in your family yeah and you
know when we first started doing ads on
YouTube right and just like an Instagram
post originally one of the things that I
made sure that I understood that people
understood and you know a few people
when it started off they would say [ __ ]
like oh you're a [ __ ] sellout and I
would always respond the same thing are
you paying my [ __ ] bills no are you
are you paying my bills right and have I
not done enough to the point where
before when YouTube started I wasn't
making a [ __ ] cent and I still created
content on a [ __ ] do but majority or
our fans are
can awesome though oh this is like a
small yeah tiny there's like one or two
comments yeah and there's just a few
people out there that just just want to
hate you just to hate you yeah and so
like I said 99% the PFAs I didn't even
have to say that because everybody yeah
[ __ ] they'll trash right and so it
was kind of odd it's like whoa
so when you see commercials and you see
everybody else do it you're just kind of
like well they can make that money when
I try to do this and my thing is I
always give gratitude right I say and
because like even on genius brain right
yeah when we get these ads it's not just
because we're doing the hard work it's
because there is a fan base that's
Lissa's listens to this you know yeah so
like I always give thanks like yell
because of you guys we get ads continue
watches the supporters thank you very
much yeah and so there is I think when
when a fan feels very disrespected in
that sense when they try to say things
and they make themselves a victim that's
where you're [ __ ] up because now
you're you're being very disrespectful
to it mm-hmm
you know what I mean though so it's like
they they kind of help build you up and
it goes to this point where now you're
saying like well boohoo me nobody's
gonna nobody's gonna give a [ __ ] that
dude
especially if you're crying you're a
[ __ ] millionaire like the [ __ ] who
gives a [ __ ] did this tour already
happen I think it's going on right now
dude there was a clip on Twitter that
cracked me up because there's this young
cat number one he can't sing to save his
[ __ ] life and he went on stage he was
just singing to the crowd and somebody
was like a make up convention music like
show and a meet-and-greet kind of thing
I think so did it sell out though I'm
not sure well he has a torso and you
sold out but I think it's doing pretty
well you know if people are gonna pay
money to go you know this kind of price
to go see him then it speaks for itself
or anything the other day yeah I just
saw that clip of him sing and I was like
you shouldn't do that just yeah just
paint you know do the makeup just do the
makeup thing call me and the times I
tweet was he goes so this is what you
pay for
just don't sing though you know yeah I
think it goes back to that weird
relationship that youtubers have with
their audience right like it's like you
we are entertainers but also like we're
not supposed to violate that we are like
we what they want that facade
that were like completely just a human
being that just does just for the love
of doing it I mean it's true but there's
a balance to it right it's like I want
you to do this but I want you to remain
like this humble regular human being
that doesn't become any successful
change like I want you just the way I
met you there's there's this aspect of
you know that youtuber becomes very
tangible and sometimes it like I said
it's like that 1% that's very weird
there's always gonna be that 1% though
yeah because they're complete idiots
yeah
but what I personally love about our
fans is our fans is like a little bit
older yeah and the average YouTube so
like 10 to 15 year olds I expect them to
do that because we don't say we would we
would have done it yeah I I did it and
they don't understand like money and
responsibilities yeah and you know I
can't expect them to yeah but our fans
are college students and above and maybe
some in high school but they're but
they're actually pretty intelligent yeah
and so every time there's a [ __ ]
that says that like I saw this one
comment the other day during I like
they're like they're like oh all they
try to all they do is they're so fake
they just try to sell things to us
and then like there was a row of [ __ ]
comments just people roasting the [ __ ]
out of this idiot yeah it's like well
what the [ __ ] are they supposed to do
like how are they gonna make money yeah
like how they're gonna pay their pills
like this is just the this is the nature
of how entertainers make money like we
give free content and you just give a
free you just you just take the time to
watch the advertisement yeah and then
sometimes purchase it if it benefits you
you no one's forcing you to [ __ ] buy
anything
yeah there's I mean I don't think that
violates the trust at all I mean
hopefully like I said most of our fans
are great and they understand that and
the support is dope yeah yeah and dude I
mean it got to the point where they got
McDonald's attention and I cut that deal
McDonald you stupid you're on the radar
though you're all I'm on your rate I've
been on your radar since day one dude
they actually hit me up I'm gonna go up
their price
you shut the [ __ ] up I have $2,000 ger
thick you can't even post an Instagram
post scribers on YouTube so watch your
mouth okay well you know what let's put
in the clip of Nick things gonna be Nick
Donald MacDonald you [ __ ] penis
sucking bass okay you know what and
that's why they love my branding so much
exist in branding our fans they
celebrate every time we get a brand new
and like some fans would just buy [ __ ]
even though they already have it like I
know like dude there's some really
dedicated letters we I'd [ __ ] love
our fans especially cuz I see this type
of other fans at my other YouTube
friends have they're like geeks dude
yeah
we have the cool ones I'm like when we
have our meeting greets I'm like man we
have like some of the best-looking
coolest people yeah it's like oh hell
yeah do you know that's probably the
trust that maybe James Charles just kind
of [ __ ] up on a little bit yeah maybe
that's that's that's that little respect
and give and go that they didn't yeah
take so you think I move too fast maybe
I mean five hundred bucks you know for
you know your audience yeah he didn't
know his audience like I know my
audience right like so there are certain
so so this is actually something that I
did recently I came out with I came out
with five different digital educational
products right one is basically a 30 day
mindset program where you know it's
called 30 days to freedom it's
completely free but I was gonna charge I
was gonna charge but I said like no this
kind of goes against what I'm trying to
do here like I did spend a lot of time
building up this program and it's like
every day I send them like a like a
10-minute audio clip yeah of different
like life lessons and things for them to
help shape their perspective in the
world right and it helps them like
basically at the end of the program
you're supposed to have more of a waking
to have a better approach to life in
mindset so then they can have the
motivation to kind of go out there
because I think a lot of people don't
have
stivity in their minds and so they need
someone to say that to them right so if
you look at any of my videos on my
channel if you look at the link I have a
link that goes 30 days of freedom so
originally I was gonna charge for that
and I didn't before this product I I
realized that the problem that a lot of
fans had is they couldn't find what
their passion was a program called how
to find your passion right so I charge
200 bucks for it I I had a you know
about a thousand people that joined
right and then um at the moment I was
like this is great but my fan base on JK
is a million on my personal channel it's
like a couple hundred thousand or
whatever right and I'm like I'm actually
not giving back to my fan base so this
goes against like what I'm doing like
they'll pay for it but it goes against
what the connection I have with them
yeah so I was like okay maybe I can do
it in different ways like they'll come
to my shops
they'll come to sip they'll pay for
those drinks they'll maybe if we come
out with the movie they can pay for that
they could pay for other things but if I
want to really be teaching good things
in a bad way if I want to be somebody
who is giving value to my fanbase right
this is just a thank-you gift
so I started releasing that out for free
yeah because I thought that at the end
of all of these programs I was gonna
just charge different rates but I was
like man II just felt it didn't sit well
with me so it's like it I think every
every creator has to come to this kind
of realization and I don't think
charging is bad for educational programs
it just depends on the relationship you
have with your fan base yeah kind of
what you started with to and it just
goes back to that point where you were
saying like I understand your fan base
yeah man yeah I mean because if one day
like let's say I want to create a boot
camp right and I want it to be exclusive
but I want it to be like this like like
a whole entire life changing experience
where we stay at this resort for like a
week but to afford that [ __ ] like for
plane tickets the resort the Oh
inclusive package food training I want
to hire like like different martial
artists and and and you know like
speakers and stuff and and so everyday
you get
like a different type of kind of like
energy and an insight right yeah if I
wanted to create this program it's gonna
cost a lot of money yeah so then at that
point it might be a couple thousand
dollars for this whole experience but
that's because I have to pay so much
money to organize and put this together
you know it's kind of surprising to like
when we we don't realize the the ripple
effect that we have sometimes so I just
came from Montclair Saint University out
in Jersey yeah Claire University
whatever um there's a couple there's a
kid that came up to me and you know when
I was trying to lose weight I was doing
it for myself right and then I just put
out a few videos like a couple videos
talking about it and speaking about it
the end goal of that wasn't really for
everybody else it was more for me and if
something somebody took away something
for me it was great but there was a kid
who lost like 80 pounds what the [ __ ]
you know that's like half of me and
there was another person - that was
talking about how like I did this I
guess this kid actually went to a Q&A
that I did a a while back mm somewhere
else
and then they took that advice and they
came to this college to see me when I
was in Jersey and they weren't in
college at the time but they decided to
go into film because of what I did and I
said well why did you go into film
because it wasn't because like I I'm a
film guy it was just more like that was
something that I was passionate about
and I kept not trying to chase what
everybody else thought that was good for
me I decided to do what I want to
because of what you you did and I said
oh [ __ ] like there we definitely do have
this ripple effects um yes like it's not
gonna reach everybody yeah but when it
does reach somebody it's very nice yeah
I'm you know when we give this advice to
us because it's not because we know
everything it's just you understand what
it's like to be in your shoe yeah so
basically we're talking to our younger
self yes 100 us all it is it's like a
therapy session yeah cuz it's so it's
almost like like you say like we're
challenging ourselves but we're just
putting it out there and it's a reminder
for us too
yeah and then it's it's almost like
we're just documenting and journal
journaling our thoughts out loud like
like this like this whole talk like what
I was thinking five years ago is not
what I think too
you know 100% and but we let it we just
put it out there we just put it out
there
and people see the evolution or they see
the change and I think from that it's
kind of like an example of maybe if they
were in that mindset to what things can
be so like let's say if you're 20 years
old right and then you watch a video of
mine of when I used to work how I used
to look what I had materialists like
like like success level wise like if you
just measure money wise or whatever
where I was at to where I am today like
they go oh wow it is possible and I'm
not that different from Joe you know Joe
was actually in a shittier place he goes
maybe I can do it right and I mean like
I think the byproduct is inspiration but
I'm not an inspiration seller like we're
not motivational speakers you're not
like we're not the Tony Robbins and
things like that although I like those
kind of things but that's not who we are
we're just talking about life and just
being who we are so I don't know what
the [ __ ] we do but whatever it is that
sometimes the the side effect and it's a
good side effect is people get inspired
by that and I'm like that's [ __ ]
awesome just like change through osmosis
or something like when we did the little
workout clinic that you oh yeah oh yeah
yeah that was crazy because you know I
knew we were gonna get a bunch of people
like I did wasn't expecting how many
people without gonna be interested in
coming out cuz this is I'm not from that
world right so I'm coming from a
completely outside perspective and like
to see how much you guys how much reach
you guys have is one thing but then to
actually see it in person and to hear
these people talk about how like man I
watch videos every day and they're like
being emotional and they're really like
pouring their heart and soul out to you
yeah and I'm sure it's the same thing
with you too
I haven't seen the first hand but I'm
sure it happens to you all the time
messages deems but it's kind of crazy to
see how people respond to you and how
much information they take from a video
you may put up that you may not think
that yeah it's gonna help anybody really
but you see it increases tenfold and all
the comments I see on your videos are
like oh my god yummy lose so much way
about you inspire me to do this
and to see it firsthand is like a
completely different animal in itself
and I'm just I was sitting there with
Jason while we were kind of [ __ ]
around but like what while we're hearing
you talk we hear everyone talk like we
were like holy [ __ ] this is this is a
different animal completely and to hear
how much you guys impact these people on
daily life it's like your jaw drops like
you really have no perspective we get
like I said I get shocked by it too you
know I get shocked even more when
they're like when a guy comes up to me
or a girl like this was one dude he came
up this guy was jacked he goes dude
you're my inspiration I was like do how
[ __ ] dare you look better than me
you're my inspiration I was a [ __ ]
there's some muscles huh yeah okay
how dare you take my advice and then
one-up me you son of a [ __ ] [ __ ] out
and subscribe now what what did you do
let me take a couple of those real quick
yeah he's stupid son of a [ __ ] yeah oh
but there's another topic that we have
to get into this podcast was brought to
you by audible baby if you haven't heard
about audible my friends you are missing
out audible is where so many inspiring
voices and compelling stories open
listeners up to new experiences and new
ways of thinking
audible members now get more than ever
members choose three titles every month
one audiobook plus two audible originals
that you can't hear any where else
members also have unlimited access to
more than a hundred audio guided fitness
and meditation programs my friends we're
talking about bestsellers business
self-improvement memoirs and more even
from people like David Goggins but you
guys know I love David Goggins that man
actually helped me kickstart my fitness
journey
so just remember people explore all the
ways listening on audible can help
improve mind body and soul with
entertainment information and
inspiration that's really cool so if you
really want one right now you can start
listening with a 30-day audible trial
and your first audiobook plus two
audible originals are free so visit
audible.com slash gb or text gb - 500 -
500 and my personal recommendation is
Rich Dad Poor Dad by Robert Kiyosaki he
did
lot to my for my education on Finance
and just basic you know saving and and
and how money works and I know it sounds
boring it's tough but the way that he
does it is is he does it in this story
and he makes it so real and personal cuz
he he does this whole journey of like
how he grew up with two father figures
he had his biological dad who was his
poor dad but he was only poor in finance
but he was rich in other things and he
had this rich dad who was actually like
financially rich but he was poor in
education but you know what I'm not
ready telling you too much just go ahead
and start listening with a 30-day trial
right now imma tell you again
audible.com slash GB or Tex GB - 500 -
500 and if you're watching this on
youtube the link will be in a
description box and you will see this
immediately just click that you could
see where it's at okay yeah so within
this whole YouTube community there was
another topic that people wanted to talk
about and this is other girl we
recovered Sanjay key news yeah she did
Tana Khan yeah I can amount out yeah so
this this girl very very popular let me
just go through this whole Wikipedia
because just to catch you up Nick Tana
Tana mojo is this like youtuber that's
pretty big and have you heard of VidCon
yeah okay so vidcon's big-ass YouTube
convention right and they've been
[ __ ] up so what she was gonna do was
be like [ __ ] that you know we're gonna
do Tanic on right next to VidCon and
we're gonna do something that's yeah she
had a jet great intentions right she was
like you know it's gonna be all made by
creators for creators she had a great
dream but she kind of like bit off more
than she can chew cuz she just you know
to put together years old by the way
it's hard yeah it's it's it's hard right
and it was a disaster yeah it was it was
it was a big [ __ ] II what so she's got
branding like what does she do yes she
put out this so I don't know what she
does yo let me just read the Wikipedia
thing it's just [ __ ] hilarious dude I
don't even have a Wikipedia so Mojo's
most famous videos are her story time
videos on February 10 2017 mojo posted
on her snapchat that she was being
investigated by the FBI
I after someone hacked into her emails
and send a bombing and shooting threat
to the McCarran International Airport so
that was her first state famous so in
2024 2017
mojo posted a video titled the n-word
know which is receive in mind she's like
why I should be able to say find the
most famous youtubers they're basically
their fanbase is like 8 to 16 year old
yeah I see so yeah you're not like
videos like UO unwrapped eggs Happy
House videos so the Edwards has received
over six point nine million views and
over three hundred thousand dislikes
dude if that's not an attention-grabber
watch this one though so in the video
mojo described an encounter where a
person on her tour later revealed to be
youtuber idubbbz i don't know who that
is told her to say the n-word
right ni g g ER with a hard-r in
response to a tweet posted by mojo to
idubbbz telling him to kill kill himself
for his comedic use of the n-word in his
YouTube videos On February 17th 2017
mojo posted a video titled an apology
for the I dub Strummer which has
received over 3 million views she's also
known for a single debut called Hefner
which was released in November to 2017
with Bella Thorne look at that so she's
basically known for a lot of you know
just a lot of drama [ __ ] yeah you know
but she has a huge [ __ ] following and
so recently her new drama which I think
I mean it started to think this [ __ ] is
planned at a certain point yeah it's
gotta be planned yeah yeah she's doing
this as the [ __ ] Pete him bar Barnum &
Bailey no [ __ ] they did that dude yeah
she uh
so basically she put out a post that she
wanted a makeup artist in exchange for
their services she was going to put them
on blast in a good way like basically
you know promote them or some [ __ ] and I
guess how I guess a few makeup artists
and a lot of people on Twitter we're
saying well you're what the [ __ ] you're
just gonna use and abuse people you're
your launch you just [ __ ] pay them
right and it was a weird thing because
this has been going on where people are
feeling like a lot of these influencers
are taking advantage of a lot of
people's services because of who they
are now my take on this I'm not sure how
popular
this is gonna be and I'm saying this as
a businessperson right if I am a [ __ ]
nobody makeup artist right and I know
this person has a huge following and
their opportunity is if I do a great job
on this and she loves the way I do
makeup and I become her permanent makeup
stylist I don't I don't think of it as a
singular job I see oh [ __ ] she's not
gonna pay me but I need this this is so
much and how I view it is I guess from
my perspective is I want to be mad
because know the amount of money that I
can make yeah from being just associated
with her and she is going to promote me
on all of her platforms that's gonna
open up 10,000 more jobs than this is
just one thing and for her I guess like
if you want to look at it like this
there's a reason why companies obviously
because you guys support us but there's
a reason why a lot of these companies
come up and they pay people like us
money to promote things Yeah right it's
because we do have that reach and if the
product is dope it reaches people who
want to get it yeah so why wouldn't that
work for somebody who works for who
she's going to promote right yeah so the
dollar value in that alone is way more
than that ones I wouldn't be surprised
if she got a hundred thousand dollars
for a shot out or yes yeah so like if
I'm its it so if a makeup artist gets
paid her rate which is like what three
hundred dollars or so in the
independence you know yeah I would much
rather take the hundred thousand dollar
value of promotion which will bring me
thousands of customers yes how many
people would jump at that yeah because I
think like in her perspective to I look
I don't I don't [ __ ] know this 20
year old girl but how I would see it as
it's more like I would ok she's [ __ ]
I could pay you the 300 bucks for the
makeup thing right I sure as [ __ ] I'm
not gonna promote you cuz I just paid
you this money for this thing so it's a
transactional thing right yeah I think
it'll be shady if she says yeah I'll
promote you and then she gets the work
done and then she never gets around the
program that's that's not up but I mean
if she's getting promoted then I'm like
that's a better value man terms are set
already
the terms are cell phone I rather pay a
makeup artist if I had a film on I would
just like no just do my makeup dude like
yeah I'm gonna [ __ ] pay I'm gonna
give you a shot out a little work yeah
so that's that's
way more Valley I might hate you I think
I don't like you at all people don't see
how important that value is and a lot of
the times we're not looking at the
bigger scope of things right I like I
understand that point of view it's like
yo makeup artists don't make a lot of
money we work on worship I get that
that's now but you're thinking of it
this [ __ ] big yeah so if you're a
makeup artists out there and let's say
somebody like I don't know Gigi Hadid
she was like you know why should you
come do my makeup and then I'll put you
on a video right now you can say on your
resume I did Gigi Hadid z-- man yeah and
that increases your value I'll buy on
you can charge more way more and on top
of that who's not to say somebody's
gonna look at Gigi hide these makeup and
say who did your [ __ ] makeup yeah
that [ __ ] is trash you know what's gonna
happen oh there's a lot of like I don't
say just rich people but there's a lot
of people in specifically the wedding
industry yeah right it's it's like just
for that special occasion you wanna you
want to say oh guess what my makeup
artist is the same makeup artist for
Gigi Hadid yeah and then like my my
floor is he is the same floors for
[ __ ] Jennifer Lopez yeah like
whatever they be that adds value to its
clout right yeah so people will pay for
that [ __ ] but that's for because people
don't understand business yeah when
people don't understand business and
they don't understand how this works
they see it as like this okay so there
are influencers that do take that take
advantage of services before sure
they're sure cuz there's guys that walk
into Barbeau with 1,000 followers and
demand a free day pass there's people
like that all the [ __ ] on a free day
pass a free membership all the time
yeah under that there's entitled
influencers man all [ __ ] day yeah
there's there's people that will go in
and in don't go into restaurants be like
look at how many followers I got give me
a free meal yeah so I think like when
Tana shows that it's like well at the it
just it just it's a resemblance of that
do you know how much you know how many
followers she does a shit-ton like a
ridiculous amount enough to be millions
Yeah right like super [ __ ] high well
you know
I don't know why everyone's all mad you
know and I kind of I thought it'd be
okay because about the whole kid thing
yeah age thing I don't get it doubt man
if any 30 year old is saying this [ __ ]
it's probably someone that doesn't
understand business at all yeah it's
like a it's like some dumb house daddy
or some [ __ ] yeah like I don't know you
know like somebody that sits home all
day and doesn't understand how the world
works yeah cuz a lot of four million
followers on this DeGraaf yeah I
wouldn't be surprised if like someone
our parents age that stupid [ __ ] like
that
just don't [ __ ] understand I know
what are you doing [ __ ] around on on
video all day yeah I know a lot of
trainers or that trained celebrities for
free or the Train like Instagram models
for free just so they could put them on
their page and they get a lot of [ __ ]
business yeah yeah it's just a step you
take yeah it's better than a [ __ ]
billion you know I still do that till
this [ __ ] day yeah you know you know
what I mean like I I did a [ __ ] film
on my own dime I mean no money off of it
you know what I mean in order to open up
opportunities for something else yeah
everybody does this you may not hear
about it or if you're not doing this you
want that's probably one of the bigger
reasons why you won't be successful yeah
you just can't be so entitled I'm think
there's more things to exchange than
money that has bigger value my opinion
yeah yeah like like that's why people go
all free work I get taken advantage of
but then a lot of you know successful
like gurus and people always say like
learn to work for free yes yeah by Gary
Vee that's all he talks about learn to
work for content content content and you
know like when I read books like Rich
Dad Poor Dad Napoleon Hill Think and
Grow Rich and just all these really
famous popular like like I don't I guess
self-help finance yes right a lot of
them say the same exact [ __ ] just in
different ways and one of the biggest
points is learn to invest in yourself
learn to work for free learn all this
stuff right and it's not really up to
you um if you're entitled to that money
at that point or not the funniest thing
happens when you are skilled when you do
have like this level
of reputation mm-hmm your value just
starts going up because people will
fight for you
in the film industry everything in every
[ __ ] industry right like like you
don't have to beg for a higher rate or
anything like that what ends up
happening is like let's say let's say
I'm a painter right and then like you
like my [ __ ] and you buy my [ __ ] and
then you tell your friends like where
you got it now your friends want to come
and buy my painting now I have too many
customers and not enough paintings Yeah
right
and I'm like well [ __ ] this takes me all
day to do maybe I could just raise my
price and then but then it just keeps
raising and raising that's the same [ __ ]
with editing or anything like if you're
a dope-ass editor right like and you
just keep killing it and killing and
people keep asking you to edit their
content yeah and it's like well I have
too much [ __ ] work now what am I gonna
do I gotta raise my prices yeah it's
it's I guess like for me I mean because
we're on the other side how I saw it was
well you were self-employed yes yeah
well your day weight was like 300 bucks
but she's actually giving you a value
that's worth like $100,000 yeah you're
actually [ __ ] your Chum yourself yeah
I just coming up like a [ __ ] and
so I you know and the other side says
well why can't she just do both who says
she's obligated to do both maybe she
doesn't want to do both because she
feels like wait so you're gonna get paid
three hundred dollars and you're gonna
get a free shot out yeah that doesn't
sound like an even trade to me it does
it yeah in either way it's like well
what why should you get both that person
who's gonna hire you sets those
standards and on top of that she wasn't
being sneaky about it she was very
upfront she knows I wanna make up bars
who wants who wants the publicity that
comes with my bread dude yeah he's it to
me if I was trying to make it as a
makeup artist or anything right this is
what I'll do so III maybe work on
weddings or things that give me paid
work right if I need to pay the bills or
I could even get me a waiter at the same
time but all the top notch clients I
would [ __ ] do my best
bend over backwards give them all free
[ __ ] non-stop so I'm always there I'm
always [ __ ] there and then I become
the go-to reliable person for every
single [ __ ] celebrity and then they're
all gonna start fighting for me five
years down a line boom I'm gonna be
charging 3040
grand every single time dude just some
just just to bring it back to how maybe
this would apply for me when I was
younger I love photography right I
didn't know that all the free work that
I was doing just working as like a like
just like a b-side [ __ ] photographer
for weddings I didn't realize that that
knowledge that I did for that free work
yeah I did a mine jug I paid sometimes
whenever the money was decent I didn't
think that free work was gonna help me
out but it did right because when when
YouTube started transferring over to be
shot on DSLR a lot of film was I already
knew how to use this camera that was the
invaluable knowledge that I got from
this it's free practice yeah it's it's
more like serious practice because
you're being pushed to practice you're
being pushed it like keep your skill set
high and you and I don't know if see
it's weird because it's like you could
say free work but that's it's still self
development you're getting better at
whatever you're doing yeah and I would
see it as investment I wouldn't see it
as free work you're investing my time in
developing myself getting better and
better and better because I don't think
I'm good enough yeah I don't ever think
I'm good enough to where I'm entitled
and every deal specifically is an
agreement between two people what you
see is value I could say hey this is my
rate $3000 and they could be like
alright that's not what you're worth or
they could be like I can't afford that
but I like your work mmm-hmm would you
take a thousand and I'm like well I'm
not doing anything that day I'll take it
no if they go I can't afford that
uh I I would you or would you be down to
do it for free but like maybe if you
stick with me you know I'm gonna give
you half of my business because you
[ __ ] went for the long run you know
that's an agreement like there's so much
freedom yeah to what you can choose to
agree upon right but I think like that
is what people are having trouble with I
say this too like you know what burn
that little [ __ ] if she said this [ __ ]
and then she didn't promote the girl
right that's [ __ ] up I can roast
Center [ __ ] out of her but at least give
her a chance to [ __ ] up first right well
you know this girl I don't she's not in
my youtube community you know so
honestly [ __ ] her but yeah from looking
from an objective point of view yeah I
think she
getting a lot of heat for no [ __ ]
reason yeah that's how I feel about it
because there's something that's gonna
do the job
yeah if you as a makeup artist sees that
deal and is like that's a [ __ ] deal and
to you that's [ __ ] her DMS are
blowing up with a bunch of people that
are like I'll [ __ ] do it I'll [ __ ]
do it yeah and at the end of the day
that's that's on her but also don't have
your own like con and named it after
yourself
and this happens I'll do something even
small like this right number one I
there's a lot of restaurants that I
support right so for example I'm not
saying I think a lot of credit for this
[ __ ] but there's a lot of like couple
taco spots I blew the [ __ ] up right I'm
all out now in order to go [ __ ]
what's that called tacos EBT that is if
I kind of open up even a bigger thing so
they were telling me like yo ever since
you did that video where you see all
these Chinese people over yeah but a
bunch of [ __ ] slant-eyed Ching chongs
are coming up and eating up these tacos
but I know they like it's not like for
me too right because I did this video
for them right and I only did it because
I really [ __ ] enjoyed the food back
to you know and I did that and you know
what I go back you know I don't they
gave me free tacos sometimes you know
like I don't expect it yeah but it's
kind of great that that is how it worked
out right they even give me free time
and you're [ __ ] no but I don't know I
just was there ya know but they're you
know like they're these things happen
all the [ __ ] time you know in my case
I wasn't expecting that type of
treatment it was they were very
appreciative and I was super
appreciative that they even make the
food right yeah how good it is so for me
I'm like I'm gonna highlight these
people just because I like their food
yeah and I think also it's like right
now there's a lot of artists that are
being taking advantage of and you know
no one ever looks at art as as work you
know like like people always they they
try to shortchange artists and then
they'll be like you know can you do this
sketch of my friend yeah I didn't do it
like whoa I thought I was just gonna get
it for free don't you enjoy drawing in
the first place like people say that all
the time and how come your paint or how
come the sketch cost a thousand dollars
when it only takes you ten minutes to do
it that's like oh sure there's a lot of
people that think this way because they
don't see you know services and
entertainment and are and things like
that
as real work yeah like to them real work
is working at a paper company or a
factory or becoming a doctor and that's
just because you know they're uninformed
and they live in a very small world yeah
so they think like oh where you're
working your passion this is awesome
like what why you have to charge so much
they don't understand the value yeah and
that's I think what a lot of people that
are starting out and and they're
struggling to be artists or people in
entertainment or they just want that
respect but it but they're struggling
through that phase we all I think been
there in the early stages right but once
they get past that I think they'll learn
so much more but there's a reason why
skilled professionals in the art world
or in entertainment get paid so [ __ ]
much like you know our our buddy Darian
yeah amazing photographer he gets paid
he goes on a like any car shoot or any
any high-fashion shoot or anything it's
twenty to fifty thousand dollars yeah
for one day of work but it's like why
well he he's able to capture this
emotion he's able to do this he's like
he's just snapping a photo but you know
he did pretty much spend 20 plus years
so you're paying for 20 plus years of
this skilled profession you know even
though it's one day's worth of work you
know and that's what people don't make
the connection out of there's definitely
value in that too especially because we
know what it's like to like just
photography alone right videography
alone cinematography these directors
there's a reason why that they make this
amount of money because they bring
something very unique to the table yeah
gives you value crazy amount of value
and I you know I understand I was on the
other side too I didn't really get it
until I started doing the war yeah and I
started hiring people who you know they
were cheaper and I was like oh this is
what it should be priced but I always
got [ __ ] [ __ ] work from it yeah and I
was like okay well this is what I buy
I'm actually buying that like you said
20 years of experience yeah and skillset
that that these other people don't have
there's a reason why they're charging
less first of all they're trying to
undercut competition yeah if there's a
reason why they're not getting any more
jobs after they work yeah
because then it's like if you pay
cheaper it's there's more of a headache
a lot of them you get what you pay for
100% an jables thank you for then on top
of that it's like these big of knowledge
yeah these big events that you want to
be captured you only get one shot at it
right yeah you just want them to make a
mistake I'm a just [ __ ] and this is
just all [ __ ] and you're like I what am
I gonna do with this right you don't
want people to practice on you know
things that are meaningful to you yeah
why would you discount it's almost like
this like you don't want a doctor to
practice medicine on you how to add a
discount right like if you're sick you
don't want someone that's just like
trying to be a doctor you want to do
that's been doing it for 40 years
yeah oh for sure like you're not gonna
go and get your LASIK done by a [ __ ]
two-for-one deal coupon yeah you know I
mean yeah bond yeah you do a Groupon
[ __ ] laser good luck being blind
jackass the [ __ ] they're lazy young
young artists and people in the service
industry like entertainment and all that
they also have to realize that the
competition in what they're doing
it's [ __ ] high I was fierce because
everybody wants this fun job right
everybody wants a dream job so there's a
lot of people that will do it for free
you can't get mad at the people that'll
do for free you just gotta compete
exactly that's just it's just how the
world works and those people are trying
in their Epson right like a lot of times
these these guys that are doing all this
work for free they're trying to get
practice they're trying to get better at
their skill and once they get really
good at their skill like you said they
can charge a higher premium but until
then they know they can't do it now and
a lot of things in life there's there
aren't definites and people want to be
comforted by the fact that they like
definite so when they do a job just to
go back to the makeup thing they go
I do job I get money and they like that
comfort right yeah they like the
security exactly and but there but the
there's this chat they go well what if
nothing comes from it you need to take
that [ __ ] risk yeah no matter if
you're gonna be a business owner I
consider makeup artists and people who
do their own yourself employed you're a
business so you need to take those
[ __ ] risks because the reward first
is missing out 300 bucks from one job to
the amount of business that you get can
get from this the reward is so [ __ ]
high that's what you should shave for if
you can't stomach that then being
self-employed isn't
it is not free so it's it's just going
back to how like we we have this bad
stigma of Millennials being like you
want all the rewards but you don't want
any of the responsibility yeah right
like it's just gonna be tougher the
reason why dream jobs and things like
that not everyone does is because it's
just [ __ ] tougher it's just harder
yeah and no like for example you think
it was easy for me to just [ __ ] drop
everything I did on my channel and do
this podcast you know like there was a
model that worked really well but in
order for me to figure out I mean that's
it's not it was for me more to feed my
self interest you know it's like a
balance it's about you know this was
mainly because I felt that number one
you know we would be on JK news and I
don't we never really get to fully
explain ourselves yeah so this was a way
for us to do it right so really
elaborate on a lot of topics so you know
there was a risk you know I haven't I
haven't got the reward yet but the risk
I'm taking an understanding that there
will be a great reward in the end yeah I
mean you're not gonna get paid for like
a year just so we're just basically
doing this for free yeah you know but
we're used to that yeah that's you you
just get used to that kind of work and I
think the big thing about working is a
lot of people are used to being an
employee yeah so hey I worked hard I
spent eight hours give me my pay and I
don't blame them for it because that's
what they're conditioned to do and
that's the reality right but then if you
do want to pursue something and you want
to be your own boss there's just a whole
set of different rules that come along
with it
yeah and you can't bring your mentality
from being an employee into this because
it doesn't work that way now you're your
own boss now you got a it you you're
gonna put in a lot of effort and
sometimes you leave with nothing and
that's just the reality of it yeah
people it's given to them it's all
perspective right because I never feel
like I leave with nothing
you know even when I get [ __ ] I feel
like oh thanks I'm glad that I learned
about this so then now you know when I
am successful and I do get [ __ ] you
know I know what to do yeah or like at
least I'm like being jacked for millions
of dollars yeah you know I rather be
jack for $100 now and learn my lesson
now
in the future where it hurts that sound
porn yeah and it's all about that
ability to be aware of what's going on
and being able to just stomach and
swallow whatever the [ __ ] just happened
you know that's that's tough and there's
a reason why entrepreneurs only make up
5% of the population it's not for
everybody
hard man it's really hard there's times
where I'm just work for someone yeah I
just want to clock out at 6 p.m. and
that's it yeah I want I want that like I
dream of that that's why I want to
retire right now yeah but it's just not
in our personality right like we it just
takes a special kind of mind and
sometimes an insane stupid kind of mind
a stubborn mind to do this type of life
and I'm not saying that it's better it
just depends on what your personality is
yeah cuz like my mom she loves a routine
she loves Authority she loves structure
she says I would never be able to do
what you're doing it would terrify me
and it would be made it would make me
sad every day yeah but she loves working
and she loves working with people one on
one that's why she became a nurse and
all this stuff
and it's like if that's your personality
then embrace that you know and then just
get a job there's nothing wrong with
working and being an employee but if if
you're like us and you're just wild and
you like to do ten different things and
and you can't focus on one thing from
the next and you just like always doing
novel new ideas and projects and you're
all over the place maybe an entrepreneur
is good for you yeah maybe you know like
you just I'd be a little bit of a crazy
person to be honest with you
you got to yeah but but also if you do
make that choice you got to understand
all the risks that come with it do
working working through getting [ __ ]
over and not getting results is hard
because it's very it's defeating and you
somehow push through that emotion that's
the that's the hard part about it I
think like when I wouldn't I would try
something and it just wouldn't work out
I have to have like this undeniable
belief but I have something to offer it
despite the fact the results results
aren't before my eyes right
now how about anxiety you know yeah like
that that's you get anxiety from that
type of [ __ ]
I feel like athleticism or like sports
or any of these things entrepreneurship
being an artist oh I I wish that the
world would try to do that once in their
lifetime open up a sense of it yeah
because there is not that many things in
this world where you're forced to take a
look at yourself and change and fight
whatever is happening yeah so like for
example like even though we have social
support right like like like we could go
through [ __ ] and we can look at each
other and be like yo man help help me
out like we could talk about it right
and then maybe if we go under we have
each other's backs
but there is no there is still no
feeling of like alright I got to do this
all by myself
mmm if I have a job it's like Oh work is
[ __ ] crazy alright I'm gonna try to do
this but you know what I'm gonna just
try to play hooky a little bit and call
in sick yeah you could call in sick and
in the work will continue going you
could come back to the job and
everything is there for you somebody
made me solve it for you like there's
there's escapes right not all jobs are
this way but like a lot of them are yeah
so so you can kind of check out when you
need to take a break reset come back you
can do it but for anyone that's an actor
artist whatever it's all on you yeah if
you take a [ __ ] break you can't yeah
people their life yeah I mean there were
definitely issues where you know some of
our personal friends - they've dealt
with people who work within a company
and they thought ahead of themselves
because they got to play with mommy and
daddy's money right so there's a lot of
times when people work for you and they
go well I'm working here on the
day-to-day so I deserve more than you
it's like well that's kind of cool but
think about it like this for us to have
built this company to this point where
you get to work this job you get to take
your picture you sit for a [ __ ] week
company still runs I'm dead I'm gone
company dies yeah right so you had this
comfort of creating things within this
ecosystem and you got to play with my
money my risk yeah right and you're not
doing that yeah that's that's the thing
you don't realize right so mommy daddy
gives you [ __ ] $100 for you to
somehow try to make this in something
better but you don't have that hundred
yeah you don't even have to reach the
pool or anything else so without me
it just wouldn't work that way and we're
trying to develop a relationship where I
respect you enough and pay you the right
amount for it but then for you to step
it and say well I don't need you anymore
it's like well cool let's play this in
your scenario out oh yeah there's a lot
of young people that join companies or
our friends companies and in there like
they kind of feel like what am i why do
I need you and they go out and try to
build their own business and they do
they fail and you think about how much
how careful you spend your own money
versus someone else's yeah you see that
all the time like especially the guys
that are like I know a bunch of people
that are trying to open up their own
gyms or businesses and you see it
happened oh yeah I'm a gambler did I go
hard
yeah but you're right though if it was
someone else's maybe you know I would
have probably dealt with a little bit
it's not a knock I think like it's just
an experience to when people feel that
way that's why like you said it would be
great if if people like that would go
ahead and try to open it up themselves
and that you give them perspective
because how it's a hard learning
experience but I feel like people grow
the most when it when it when they face
that if you've used some sort of empathy
right haves you a window into like oh
this is what this person deals with on a
regular base empathize with the person
that feels like they're they're valuable
like that because you are valuable yeah
a hundred percent you are but because
you lack empathy and you lack experience
you can't you can't see outside of your
bubble right now because all you see is
your value but you don't see the other
value that's been given to you to allow
you to flourish my boss has unlimited
money what they don't tell you is hey
the company did bad this year
they didn't pay themself yeah but all
the employees got paid and all the
employees got to take care of their
family yeah but this year his family was
kind of broke yeah like they never
talked about things like this and I
think you know the more we have this
imagery of like bosses and and top dogs
as being like this greedy
rich person but the majority of
companies in America are you know
they're they're small companies that's
what makes the country run like like
small businesses small business yeah
yeah like mid-sized up to 100 people
like and a lot of them are very invested
with their employees it's like a family
like it's like they work hard together
we just get a bad bad rep because of the
big multinational like billion-dollar
companies that does crazy moves
we know Walmart yeah they so they they
have this bad idea of oh you [ __ ] one
percenters yeah you you yeah you CEOs
all these guys so [ __ ] up it's like oh
come on man like there's a huge
population of people out there that are
good bosses and good company owners but
you're you're tying them up with these
Psychopaths that are [ __ ] the up the
world you know that's not the same
people yeah for sure did pick up follows
ball and I've been doing this [ __ ] on
this [ __ ] couch I just I do wish one
thing though so like when I was when I
was younger I wish someone told me the
difference between effort and if
ineffectiveness hmm so like so so a lot
of us feel that hey man we put in a lot
of [ __ ] effort I want to be
recognized for that through pay yeah
right so I feel like everybody should be
recognized for their effort like if you
[ __ ] worked hard everyone should be
like a dude that was dope thank you or
at least acknowledged right yeah yeah
yeah like like like oh that was good
good effort man but keep going right but
effort doesn't equal effective yeah so
so for example like I could be a very
hard-working salesman mmm but I could
sell no cars yeah cuz I could I could
try and try and try and people just
don't like me or maybe my cells like
method just didn't work
I could sell no cars but I could tell my
boss all day like dude you know I'm in
here before anybody else is here and I
leave before after everybody else does
it's like cool you sold one Civic yeah
still gonna tell me hey you're not
effective yeah and then you might start
getting pissed
the other guy that comes in for one hour
and he sells 10 cars and you're just
like man [ __ ] this guy doesn't work as
long as I didn't work as hard as I do I
mean even in the stand-up comedy world
they did that too internet comedy
comedians yeah
because they'll be like all I worked so
hard I've been I've been grinding for 20
years I've been doing these little bars
for 20 years who the [ __ ] are you but
it's like funnier than you you [ __ ]
yeah but then Internet people use the
internet because they're being effective
it's like yo I could reach millions of
people mm-hmm so I'm gonna put my
content out there and a millions of
people are gonna like me versus talking
to ten people at a time they're you know
so if people understand the difference
between the two they'll start to realize
you want to become effective with your
work not a lot of efforts great but
efforts not gonna produce misplaced yeah
definitely yeah and it's only an
individual at that point it's on the
shitty salesman to say okay this guy is
selling 10 cars in one hour
yeah what the [ __ ] is he doing that I'm
not yeah it's on that person and yeah
you can't do that then you're not gonna
thrive as entrepreneur yeah that always
what do it especially goes hand in hand
with [ __ ] health man yeah like people
are like well I [ __ ] I run three
miles of [ __ ] day how come I haven't
lost weight I don't know cheeseburger
boy yeah you know like yeah would you
wait 17 cheeseburgers dude the when
people tell me like oh I clean and I'm
like all right let me see your food luck
show me the food log and it just [ __ ]
yeah well yeah they're awesome denial
exactly then again in their head they're
just like oh like yeah I'm I'm doing
great
yeah oh [ __ ] yeah I'm working out which
is good you know but you're not getting
XY and Z because you're not putting in
you just work it's like working hard on
the wrong [ __ ] I think people should
recognize and you should deserve
something for yeah yeah it's like man
that's just not how the world works
yeah okay yeah you're doing yourself a
disservice didn't you're gonna be very
stressed out yeah cuz I'm not gonna run
like three miles a day you know in my
thing right and then it's not like when
I was fat I didn't know the reason why I
was fat hey are you yeah I mean like I
lied and I enjoyed every [ __ ] second
yeah
I [ __ ] enjoyed it I just I think you
know people just get defeated yeah just
just yeah cause it's like I'm trying so
I could get it though because I was
there so I'm trying so hard I'm trying
so hard you're changing a life you're
changing everything that you know how to
do that you normally do
yeah for this like this it's if you
don't get immediate results yeah yeah so
the sooner I accepted it's all about
being effective yeah that's when I was
like I'll change yep I gotta accept that
yeah yeah oh well [ __ ] man that's
another hour come up BAM boom boom boom
boom dude my ears hurts so bad why
because we've been too loud
no it's just like alright because you
got cauliflower Oh bro my ears are like
I'm afraid that's gonna bars yeah
they're going to I hurt so bad that's
our cue to episode shrink your [ __ ]
years you bastard well I wish I'd fancy
headphones like you oh these are
actually pretty nice these actually come
or maybe you should get earbuds just for
this dude yeah [ __ ] I'll be fine
princess anyways guys check us out on
every single audio platform we're
talking about that iTunes give us that
five star Spotify everything else
YouTube comments leave below let us know
about the topic she wants to talk about
let us know what you think about the
whole situation with though I mean just
because like we're coming from a
perspective of people who are business
owners yeah we see behind the scenes yes
maybe there's something that we missed
you know that's yeah I think that's
pretty important because the audience
has their own perspective and when they
could write down in the comments it
gives me a little insight into their
world because I did lose connection by
being a content creator yeah I'm no
longer just an audience member and yeah
so I am I'm audience member I can speak
from okay so what so you're saying you
know you're an entertainer to you you're
professional fighter you're
self-employed you you train people so I
think most of those are wrong but yeah
happy to do that yeah yeah prosody was
right so we're gonna dick on the side
nobody wants my services though what can
they find you Nick the ear on Instagram
or Nick the ear comm you know hey me up
you guys have any questions about
anything regarding David's personal life
and access to his keys his cars all that
stuff and Moodle I will sell you guys
his use underwear just DM me and we'll
make those exchanges happen yeah they
look like purse Joe - all right y'all
we'll see you all next time
happy birthday Baba yes